in a sense the numbers were a bit of a
shocker I mean you know we both know
that it was good because the headline
rate came down but the call rate went up
and now look at interest rate
expectations up to you know five and a
half percent are you comfortable with
that with the bank of England doing
whatever it takes to bring down
inflation even if that potentially would
precipitate that recession that you've
almost just avoided yes because in the
end even if there's the inflation is a
source of instability and if we want to
have Prosperity we want to grow the
economy if we want to reduce the risk of
recession we have to support the bank of
England in the difficult decisions that
they take and indeed I have to do
something else which is to make sure the
decisions that I take as Chancellor very
difficult decisions to balance the books
so that the markets the world can see
that Britain is a country that pays its
way all these things mean that monetary
policy at the bank of England fiscal
policy by the chancellor are aligned and
only this week the managing director of
the international monetary fund praised
the authorities in the UK for acting
decisively to bring down inflation and
what I would say Ed is that when the
Prime Minister announced that it was his
objective to halve inflation in January
there were some people who who derided
that they said well it's automatic
inflation's going to come down in any
anyhow there's nothing automatic about
bringing down inflation it is a big task
but we must deliver it and we will even
if it means precipitating a recession
well um we will deliver this task and we
will make sure that the government plays
its part the bank of England plays its
part but it is not a trade-off
between tackling inflation and recession
in the end the only path to sustainable
growth is to bring down inflation I
wonder about life sciences because
obviously you have a big event a set of
announcements about what you're doing
for that sector would you say this is
picking winners because you're picking
certain sectors that you believe have a
shot
it's not picking winners and I think
it's a very important question
to ask what happened in the 1970s was
that we picked companies like British
Leyland put money into them and it
didn't work and we have learned that we
can support sectors but the sectors we
support we want to Foster Fierce
competition between the players in those
sectors but we are completely clear that
the sectors we're backing the sectors
where Britain does really well
technology Life Sciences Advanced
manufacturing clean energy these are the
sectors that are going to make us
prosperous and successful in the 21st
century there's a non-green energy a lot
of speculation now in fact we've heard
that the chairman of tartar is coming
here to Downing Street next week to have
a meeting a lot of speculation there's
going to be a gigafactory opened up what
can you tell us about that
well I can't talk about any commercial
discussions you'll understand that but
what I can say is that we understand
that prime minister and I understand
that we're in a global race to attract
investment and we will always do what it
takes to make sure the UK remains
competitive including potentially
subsidies for people if they want to
build a big gigafactory well we have a
one billion pound Automotive
transformation fund and we know that
other countries are supporting companies
who make these Investments it's
obviously good for the UK not just to
create these jobs but also to transition
to Net Zero and the transition to
electric cars is a very important part
of that